[Music]
this is sky news welcome to our show
dedicated to interviewing people who
have something to say about the world
today they'll be from politics sport
business entertainment public life or
they'll be everyday people caught up in
the events of our times i'll be putting
my questions to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening gordon brown dominated
british politics for a generation but
that was a very different britain in a
very different world
he knows what it's like to be in
opposition to run the treasury to run a
government and to help the world out of
a crisis and he still believes he has
the solutions but since leaving office
in 2010 things have changed so much
are gordon brown's ideas still relevant
or perhaps a return to brown's vision is
exactly what his successor circus needs
to lead labour out of the wilderness i
spoke to him in his only in-depth tv
interview to accompany his new book
release
one thing's for sure we do need
someone's vision for the economy rising
prices falling wages industrial strife
job shortages millions still on benefits
our talk to work and pension secretary
to raise coffee she's one of the
cabinet's less known but most thoughtful
ministers about the coming storm
also ahead a voice from the world's most
secretive country chi hun park grew up
in north korea and was brought up in
desperate hardship her friend celine
chai is also korean but she's from the
south and grew up to be a global banker
they've written a book together with
tales of prison defecting and friendship
and we get to hear their amazing story
the former prime minister gordon brown
was a new labour leader of the country
between 2007 and 2010. back then he was
considered moody sometimes angry i went
to scotland to meet him and find out how
he sees the world now
gordon brown thanks so much for spending
some time with us today we're here to
talk about your book seven ways to
change the world but before we get on to
that and globalization and some of the
challenges climate and so on i did want
to talk to you about things closer to
home things affecting people around your
home in fyfin in scotland's central belt
evidence of the cost of living crisis
can you describe to me what you're
seeing at the moment we've now not only
got food banks we've got closed banks
we've got bedding banks we've got baby
banks
we've got fuel banks
we're now in a situation where charity
is replacing the welfare state as the
last line of defense
the last protection for people in
greatest need
and we're about to go into winter when
things are going to get in interminably
worse
and already the charities i'm working
with locally are preparing for that
winter by stocking up blankets stocking
up duvets stocking up even sleeping bags
hot water bottles because people are
deciding that they can't heat their
homes but they have to
find a way to heat themselves so i don't
think the government
understands the scale of the desolation
and the desperation in communities that
they really don't visit
and i think it's up to us to point out
that unless you have a plan for this
winter and probably to take us through
this cost of living crisis
then millions of people are going to
suffer when they could be helped and at
the same time we're not going to get
back uh to the growth that is necessary
to deal with the cost of living problems
in the first place so what we need is a
plan we don't know what their pathway is
at the moment they go from one month to
the other the whole purpose of making
the bank of england independent was that
they would take a long-term view of the
future and so we need a a pathway to
stable prices sounds like you find it a
bit frustrating watching what's going on
down in westminster at the moment well i
think it's pretty clear what needs to be
done the country is being asked to
accept austerity because
the wage rises that people are being
offered are way beyond the rate of way
below the rate of inflation uh public
services
are diminishing in many respects as
certain millionaires so people on health
service waiting lists and there is no
explanation coming from the government
there is no plan they don't seem to have
a clue what to do now we have global
events that are impinging on us the fuel
crisis obviously globally we've got
obviously uh food crisis globally we've
got debt facing some of the poorest
countries on top of covert climate
change and conflict
and there are things that we can do
globally and we should be taking the
lead
but equally you need a national plan and
you need to explain it there should be a
television uh broadcast by the prime
minister explaining what needs to be
done you cannot go through a winter when
people are being asked to take the
biggest cut in the standards of living
for 50 years and not ask people uh to
understand what you're trying to do and
give them a plan for what they're saying
we are
going to lay out a plan i think before
summer recess though i think they are i
don't think it will be the sort of plan
i'm talking about from what i hear
you've you've got to think two to three
years
uh it's got to be about growth because
the biggest achilles heel for our
economy is not just the cost of living
crisis is the failure to grow
that means that standards of living have
not risen for 10 years
and our public services cannot improve
and so you need to lay out a long-term
plan now it should have been in
actually it should have been in boris
johnson cbi speech last november when he
talked about peppa pig instead of
talking about an industrial strategy
when he lost his he lost his notes when
he hadn't actually thought through what
the consequences of going through this
winter were going to be
it should have been in the budgets that
richie sunik have done i think he's had
three budgets this year already you
think you should have a fourth don't you
of course because there's got to be a
plan you've got to explain to people
what's happening
you've got to show how you're going to
get back to stable prices you've got to
show also how you're going to help those
people in greatest need the people that
i'm very worried about who are going to
suffer heavily this winter but you've
also got to show you've got a way
through and that's one two three four
years
where you've got to show people that
you've got a plan for growth and a plan
for industry and it's absolutely clear
to me that there is no strategy to do
this and the final thing of course we've
got to do is repair our trading
relations if we cannot repair our
relations with europe and america and
we're at war if you like with both of
them for different reasons but all
related
with america well with america over
ireland because america will not sign a
trade treaty with britain as long as we
cannot sort out the issues relating to
ireland president biden i asked him
about this explicitly
last year last september and he did say
that he thought the two things were
separate that there was a trade deal and
then there was the good friday but he
may think that but the american congress
will not think that there's no chance of
a trade deal between britain and america
unless we can sort out the problems that
arise in in ireland and of course
there's no chance of getting better
trade relationships with europe unless
we can sort these problems
out as well and that's very much part of
our future because if we cannot export
to the leading markets in the world
and cannot do successfully with these
new industries and new technologies then
the cost of living crisis will be with
us for years and not just temporarily
the consequence of a very tight labor
market
and inflation
has been also a return to trade union
militancy some would say you might not
but some would say the government is
determined not to compromise on public
sector pay is that the right stance well
what the government's got to do is get
people around the table and explain to
them what's happening and look if you
can get inflation down in the next two
years from nine percent or eleven
percent now
to three four or two percent then you
can present people with a program you
can say to people here's a package
you're going to benefit later
because your wages will rise as long as
we can take action now but there's
nothing of this in everything they say
in fact what the chancellor is holding
out for is the leadership of the
conservative party by talking about tax
cuts all the time
it seems to me though in terms of pay
rises in the short term you seem to
agree with the prime minister this is
what he said to me
uh at choggam when i asked him about pay
rises for public sector workers he said
what we can't have is a situation in
which increases in pay are wiped out by
further increases in prices that's why
you've got to be responsible
he's right isn't he that wage increases
could lead to an inflation rate but you
you wouldn't lift wages to six seven
eight percent
would you but he's talking about a
situation where he's trying to allege
that some groups of workers are
leapfrogging over other groups of
workers that this is a sort of uh
traditional wage bargaining run where
people are trying to get ahead of others
all the time in fact everybody in the
country is facing a cut in the standards
of living and he's got to explain to
people how if he's asking them to accept
sacrifice now what he's going to do for
them to benefit later so what you might
say you're going to have to take three
percent this year but next year i will
try and increase it to x percent or
well i'm not going to get in the
business of figures because these are
parts
you actually understand that your former
chancellor you get this stuff
as well as a former president i'm saying
if look if we could get back to growth
and that would be let's say two and a
half or three percent growth coming out
of this
then that's an extra 50 or 60 billion a
year for the economy that's an extra 20
billion of revenues for the for the
exchequer to pay for the things that we
we need we need to pay for including
helping people who are in difficulty and
what i think is missing is any sense of
the long term
you know this is a this is a prime
minister who thinks only from scandal to
scandal or crisis to crisis and it's
really sad
you don't hold him in
much regard do you i don't i don't want
to be personal about it i know but i
think it's only because you've said a
few things about the peppa pig and
not having a plan i was i was using
peppa pig and i look he went to the cbi
and people were expecting to set out a
policy for industry for the future
probably the most favorable audience he
he he could get if i had been there i
would have been setting out my policy
for industry and and for growth
and he not only lost his his notes in
his way but he but he definitely lost
his way in terms of any direction and
and and really since last november when
we've had three budgets uh consequent to
that there has been no strategy and no
plan and it's really important for for
any country going through these
difficulties to explain these are global
factors that we we are trying to control
but we're working collectively now it's
no good the chances are the prime
minister saying they're beyond our
control most of these global forces can
be managed by international cooperation
but at home i think the lack of a plan
and the lack of a sense of direction is
really what is the beginning of the end
for this government yeah my only
observation was you don't seem to think
he's a very serious guy
i mean that's the impression you're
leaving me
but beth you're trying to get me to be
personal about these these are really
big issues of i just think
now if you ask me would i have been
organizing parties in downing street no
and i didn't and people asked me why
there were no parties in down history
but but equally i i i don't want to to
to to relegate this this is an issue of
policy affecting the standards of living
of millions of people across this
country also affecting the health
service and our ability to finance it
where i think we could do better and
affecting the the general level of
public service let's move on to your
book and some of the global issues now
that you have been thinking quite deeply
about the seven ways to change the world
in the book you identify seven grave
dangers that require global solutions
that was in 2021 now in the early summer
of 22 you've written a new prologue
of your book which boils down to three
really three issues covered climate and
war
but isn't what is happening now in
ukraine of those three
existential issues isn't it now really
that one issue in that there's an
argument that says that we can't deal
with anything on the social democratic
agenda
domestically or internationally until
that situation in ukraine is settled
that it literally just
blankets out everything else well let me
say first of all after this shopping
center massacre that has been taking
place in the last day and the numbers of
deaths
clearly a pre-meditated attack
organized by putin himself
to scare the ukrainian people
there is no argument now against
holding him responsible for this
uh bringing him before a a war crimes
tribunal indicting him
and the best way to do that would be to
set up a special tribunal now ahead of
the international criminal court
arena for the crime of aggression which
is provable and demonstrable without
having to go into a huge amount of
evidence about individual cases of war
atrocities
and he should be indicted and he should
be charged and even in his absence he
should be found guilty and so should the
cabal around him there is no there is
nothing that putin understands other
than strength there is nothing he
understands other than
uh us showing that we are prepared to
stand up to him and that he will exploit
every weakness that we show
and i know that from looking at his
record and having
worked
in the time that he was prime minister
and president and i was prime minister
uh and i think we've got to send out a
very clear message that none of these
crimes can go with impunity
so you don't think that there should be
a process waiting for you you think that
there should be an expedited process
to charge him as a war criminal i think
that the crime
the crime of aggression is obvious no i
think he does care but the problem is mr
brown partly that if you look at how
many countries around the world have
actually sanctioned russia it's 20 of
the world
can you
coalesce the world to
charge putin or the world's divided on
this so this is what has happened we've
got nato unity
but we've got global disunity
so 82 countries either abstained or
voted with russia when they were brought
before the human rights council for
violations of human rights as you say
about 150 countries are not imposing
sanctions
and the reason i think goes back to some
of the events of the last few years why
is it almost the whole of africa the
whole of asia
latin america
mexico and brazil included in latin
america
much of the middle east are refusing to
impose sanctions or to take any action
against uh
putin and it's because they feel first
of all double standards i think they
feel that we we are concerned about
ukraine but not about civil wars that
happen in other countries but second
that they don't feel
they do not feel that the globalization
that has been led by the west is really
working in their favor going back to
ukraine before we move on
uh the prime minister's view
is that ukraine shouldn't be coerced
into what he would describe as a bad
piece and he's worried that
the economic fallout of this war
might compel other countries to now try
and force
or encourage ukraine into
a piece in which perhaps some of the
land is annexed what's your view of that
do you agree with boris johnson on that
i i agree with him about the importance
of making sure
that we do everything in our power to
protect the sovereignty of ukraine what
i think however is is missing here is is
the greater coordination in policy now
there's been a huge amount of
coordination in terms of
the first round of sanctions there's
been a huge amount of coordination in
terms of saying we'll give you this or
that military support i think boris
johnson perhaps should spend more time
trying to bring people together to agree
on what the objectives are for the next
stage of this of this enterprise and of
course we want to support ukraine and of
course there is a there is there is an
issue about where you move from a
defensive position that is you're
helping ukraine defend itself to what
russia would see as aggression
but these are things that i think we've
got to discuss together and i think
there is a danger that america britain
germany france italy all going different
directions over the next year
kierstarma he
is the labour leader obviously
the question i want to ask you is do you
think he sealed the deal with the
british public
in that some of his colleagues as you
will know
have sort of criticized kierstama for
being too boring to quote them
um
it's kind of a bit true does he come
across as a bit boring a bit loyally
not a charismatic leader everyone what
do you think every criticism that has
been visited on uh kierstama was visited
on me tony blair jim calligan
uh harry people didn't call tony blair
boring did they yeah but they they did
say that labor didn't have an exciting
enough agenda at certain points i mean
you remember in 1997 people said it was
too modest and and everything else but
all these criticisms are thrown at labor
leaders and they're mainly thrown of
course by
a conservative press that's gotten
interested in defeating the labour party
my advice to give someone is usually not
to take my advice because it's better
that he does his own thing but my advice
to him has always been not to not to
listen to this and to get on with the
job that he set himself one one to to
prepare the party so that it's seen by
the public as a national party that's
capable of representing the whole
country secondly to develop his policy
and third to put across his policy to as
wide a group of people as possible and
that includes talking to no voters in
scotland as yes voters as well as no
voters in scotland and it includes
talking to
lead voters as well as remain voters in
england we've got to find a way of
bringing this country together and i
think kia stammer is better placed to do
that than boris johnson do you think the
prime minister lacks integrity clearly
uh he
he he has broken the law uh clearly he
has
he has failed to follow the rules fairly
fairly he's evaded his own ministerial
code all these things are true and i
think he's admitted that to be the case
the question i think
that he didn't quite answer at the
weekend is whether he's going to change
would you have resigned if you were him
at this point well i could i'll look
i'll be honest i could not have imagined
myself
breaking
the law in downing street during during
a a crisis like like we've had and
therefore i i i could not have stayed in
office if i thought i'd let people down
in that way i've got to ask you this
scottish independence
do you think that there will be a second
referendum in your lifetime or my
lifetime
i i wouldn't rule out that but i would
say that scotland deserves better than
what's happening at the moment i mean
we're in a endless debate about uh
constitutional details that is leading
us
nowhere
i would like to see and i would like to
put forward a far more ambitious plan
for the future of scotland one that
solves some of the constitutional
difficulties deals with the economic
challenges we face
builds a far better social fabric for
this country and that's really the issue
for the people of scotland if the issue
is posed as change
through independence versus no change
and the only alternative is independence
then independence will will will be
something that people would be prepared
to consider
but if it's one kind of change for
scotland staying within britain but in a
better situation both in terms of its
economic
social and political future
as against independence then the change
that is within britain will win
do you think kirsten will be the next
prime minister of this country yes i do
do you really yes i do
okay thank you thanks for your time
gordon brown there a former prime
minister still brimming with ideas isn't
he well look if you scan this qr code on
screen now you can watch all of our
interviews online and all the previous
episodes of the show if you so desire
well stay with us because coming up next
i'll be speaking with ceiling and
chi-hung two korean women who were
raised to hate each other until a chance
encounter changed everything
[Music]
back north korea is one of the most
isolated states in the world for
neighbouring countries it's considered a
threat for the people who live there
that means famine constant surveillance
and strict rules
chihun park has now escaped north korea
ceiling chai is south korean raised to
hate one another they met in 2014 in a
chance meeting and have now forged a
friendship and written a book the hard
road out telling the story of two
koreans
thank you so much
both of you for joining us today it's
really great um
to meet you both and and for you to tell
the story which i hope viewers will find
interesting um
you've just published a book uh the hard
road which you wrote together which
tells the story of of your life chi hung
uh but before we get on to how we met
you met
um and the collaboration can i start
with you
uh you now live in bury with your family
but that's not where your life started
was it what was it like
growing up in north korea
when i lived in north korea i didn't get
any informations from outside countries
so
we didn't know too much about what's
happening outside the country so in
north korea is called their socialism
country but that is not true that is a
totalitarian
dictatorship country
so every morning we wake up same times
it's 5 00 a.m you know there is a in
apartment it's a captain it's shouted
the doors wake up
so so almost like being in prison in a
prison race that's true that is 21st
centuries
is prison in north korea and also modern
slavery lives in north korea nowadays
when you were growing up there though
you said that it was very isolated you
couldn't um you didn't know what was
happening outside of north korea
did you feel unhappy or did you just
accept that that was your existence that
was your way of life
because we are slavery so celebrities
never talked about the future or next
moment or something that so we always
are happy with the government is
not personal happiness is always his
political happiness something happened
to you and that you wanted to
escape you fled north korea what what
was the thing
what happened in your life that made you
think i have to leave
very very few people ever leave
north korea and come to tell a story do
they so how did that come about that is
my father's courage you know that my
brother had been lawyer is a workers
party in north korea and
he always duty and respected the
government and he also talked to us when
you grow up you also joined the work
party and respected
your legion but
this 1998 last time during this old laws
march and three million people died of
starvation
yes yes i mean and my uncle also died of
stabilization in front of me
and yeah and my younger brother had
these problems so my father last week
was save your younger brother so leave
north korea so that time i didn't
understand why
but
that is my father's courage bring to
nowadays my politicians so so you fled
with your younger brother
because of the famine and your
other brother said you must leave the
country your uncle had died so you fled
to china
basically because you were fearful of
the famine and that you would starve yes
yes
so you didn't feel it for political
reasons you fled for survival
then what happened to you in china once
in china it's language also different
but i never talked about the language
problems first i met that is the korean
chinese people and
he lives in not his biggest
houses is a kind of is poorest is
bungalow but they have lots of rice eggs
and meat yes so he gave to us this nice
meal yes i was shocking because
socialism country is a great country
but china is not a socialism country but
these people is always full mountain
eating very vital yeah well they they
had much better food than you yes yeah
yeah but then you you had a child in
china what happened did you have a child
in china or you were sent back to north
korea what happened to you because it
was the first memories a chinese person
gave to us a nice meal but not all
people nice and nice us yes so then i
was a human trafficking
chinese men you were so yeah how old
were you that time i was 29 yeah
so
this is not only is my experience that
is all north korean female and girls
experience and this is nowadays is
smokeless human tropicals they're
waiting the border areas kidnapping
females and the girls and so you
you were trafficked you were sold to
chinese men and you became pregnant yes
yeah and then you were sent back yeah to
north korea yeah so
my child was born in china and he was a
statelessness child because chinese
government never accepted to her
to him in china and so they never gave
to them identifications so my son was
never been to hospital did he come back
he didn't come back with you to north
korea yes yes because he was born in
china yes not original north koreans so
i alone sent back to north korea because
chinese government never accept refugees
in china
was it awful that's awful and i think
people can't imagine what's happened
inside presence when we sent this
political it personally sent the
security prison camp and
we went to today and they post this body
searching which is off all cloth clothes
and the body search it and that is not
the female guy it's males and then
you sent back to north korea and you
escape you escape for a second time yeah
how does that happen what happened um
you know the first time i lost all
family members my brother died in north
korea and i lost my younger brother too
and i still don't know that my younger
brother survive or not
so i lost to all family members so my
child is my own family
and i am mother i have duty to save my
uh son so your son is in china yes sir
my son is you've been sent back to north
korea and you get back yes sir your goal
now is i'm going back to my baby
yes so in prison i only talked about my
son so i just survived i have to survive
and one day united my son let's come
back to the two of you now
um
celine you are
south korean
you're together you've collaborated on
this book
um how did how did you meet and how did
this collaboration
come about
um
the
the moment i met her
was
quite extraordinary we met by accident
i was hired by amnesty international
to translate
an interview
because they wanted to do a documentary
on her life
and um
just to give you a little bit of context
i grew up in south korea
because my elementary teacher told me so
that north koreans had
red horns on their head
that north koreans were
evil
communists therefore dangerous
and
when i found myself sitting in front of
her like this
here i was thinking
what am i doing here
how am i going to
justify this to the korean government
mind you the two koreas are still at war
there is a national security law
in place
that prevents us from engaging with each
other
i have to report myself to the south
korean embassy otherwise i'm going to
get into trouble so all kind of things
go through my mind
so you initially felt quite hostile is
that fair to say you felt hostile oh
it's more than hostile you were free i
was afraid
i was uh regretful that i was there
i was shocked just the stories that
she's telling you today the story in and
of itself is shocking enough but then um
exponentially uh shocking for me because
i had to digest what was happening to me
given the background i grew up with yes
so my father was a south korean diplomat
yeah so you had to completely
recalibrate everything everything that i
was told
was all of a sudden
completely also but in the air so you
were fearful of retribution from the
south korean government both oh it's
fearful for both what you do inside
north korean side fear would happen to
you well a south korean side i i wanted
to make sure that i didn't do anything
against the law yes you would be an and
the north korean side well north koreans
you know is it though north korea is the
same
hostile to south korea and america
the purpose of this book um is telling
your story but
i mean
now you've explained that to me a south
korean and north korean writing a book
together i mean that blew that one apart
didn't it i mean so that's quite
politically
for people in south korea that that's
this is a massive deal it was only very
difficult
situation to be in
but um
so
apart from that original trauma
with time
not that i turned the page ever
this woman changed my life eight years
ago
so i never turned the page but
there was this
desire of
finding out why is it that i was so
so shocked by this event what is going
on
it gave me the envy of exploring a
little more
this nonsense of
two
korean women speaking the same language
um looking alike
um
uh eating the same food living in
england raising families we we all do
similar things
and yet we were supposed to be enemies
yeah so i needed to dig into that
three years along the line after some
couple of random meetings she approached
me and said would you like to write
my story i find that there is a line at
the end of the book without giving too
much away
that says your story is proof
that there lies a deep desire for
reunification
of north and south career do you think
to each of you do you think in your
lifetimes you you might see
live to see united career
um
i would like to say that not knowing the
answer to that
at least there are things that we can do
to prepare for an eventual reunification
and um
england is actually probably one of the
only places in the world where we could
be doing something about this because as
you know there are about 800 north
korean refugees living in the uk
about 30 000 south koreans
and um we we can
practice
living together
and chihuahua what do you what do you
think about that i mean you grew up in
north korea now you have kim jong-un
do you ever see a world where there
won't be a a totalitarian state in north
korea can you
can you imagine it or do you think it
is impossible to achieve my hope is now
is because britain is a joint korean war
so britain is still the empowered
country and still the power so british
society have been teaching again to
people how is communism and socialism is
is what is affected our society and they
destroyed our freedoms so that is could
be changed our
mind first and then people truthfully
looking for what's happened inside north
korea
yes well look hopefully your book the
hard road will begin to tell that story
and people will read it and better
understand
the divisions well thank you both for
coming in and talking to me and thanks
for telling me that story it was really
a pleasure to meet you both thank you
thank you so much for having us
stay with us because coming up next i'll
be talking to the secretary of state for
work and pensions to raise coffee
[Music]
we're in a cost of living crisis fueled
by high food and energy prices and now
there's a labor shortage too a shortage
of people to do the jobs that are needed
to keep the uk economy growing so what
are the government going to do about it
ministers say they have a plan i met the
work and pension secretary trace coffee
for a bird's eye view of the capital and
to find out what that plan is
trade coffee thanks for coming on the
show although we're in a pod not in the
studio which actually i think i prefer
i think i should do all my interviews in
here but anyway that's a whole different
thing um look thanks for coming on the
show
uh i went back to the last time we did a
sit down on my interview june it was
just after the fast lockdown it was in
october 2020 you were preparing at the
department for potentially four million
people
unemployed and at the heart of the final
quarter of that year redundancies were
the highest level at the highest level
on record you'll remember it fast
forward two years we've now got record
on employment job vacancies are at
record numbers to 1.3 millions and we've
got shortages in certain sectors can you
unpack it a bit for me about what's
going on because the market looks quite
confusing
well of course when we went into covid
we didn't quite know what the impact was
going to be uh what we did know is that
we had to close down significant parts
of the economy and in particular people
who may be on quite low incomes so
whether it's hospitality retail and
that's why we prepared and we're ready
and absorbed actually a record number of
uc claimants coming in who needed help
at the time so fast forward that we
recruited people to help people get
ready to get back into work you know we
had a few fits and starts and during the
pandemic but i think what was important
was obviously the importance of the
furlough scheme so a lot of people
stayed attached to their employers but
also as we started to get vacancies
coming we were well placed uh having
built that relationship with uh
claimants to get them ready and to get
them into work but we needed quite a big
shove i think at the beginning of this
year because we did have record and
still have huge numbers of vacancies
and we just needed to make sure learning
from what we did with kickstart with
young people
getting that right across our entire
claimant group
so you've got more people into work but
what people watching will be seeing are
shortages in industries i went to
my dad's village in norfolk over the
jubilee weekend and the local pub had
shut down because they couldn't get
staff
aviation shortages you know mayhem in
airports
what's going on in terms of shortages
because it's not an immigration issue if
you actually look at the figures 18 of
the current workforce are immigrants
that's the highest proportion ever so so
what what's going on why are there so
many vacancies well we've got a half a
million people into work in just the
last five months and
learning by bringing employers into our
job centre um making sure that we got
rapid turnaround with decisions and
coaching people if they hadn't uh hadn't
been successful but i think more broadly
what we've seen of the 1.3 million
vacancies quite a lot of those are high
skill you're right and uh that's uh we
need to keep working now on how we bring
people out of economic inactivity and
that's why i'll be working and i'm
working with other departments across
government how we make that happen i
don't think it is about more information
or immigration for certain sectors do
you think you accept that or you don't
well one of the things that we have is
the migration advisory committee uh in
regards to thinking about high-skilled
jobs where we don't have sufficiently
enough people and that was one of the
things of leaving the european union we
were able to move to our points-based
immigration system we have seen a lot of
people come into the country but
thinking a little bit more broadly you
know you were talking about rural
norfolk and aspects of that what we've
done for example in i give you a great
example and madison and kent we brought
together farmers uh we brought together
uh our claimants and we actually did
some uh kind of trials some work coach
experience and we actually started
filling jobs in those sort of fruit
pressing picking areas so we can make it
happen by bringing our employees
together and that's been the success of
way to work and
but choice coffee in terms of where we
are now
we've got 1.3 million vacancies but the
other thing that is quite
surprising i find surprising is that we
have
5.3 million people one in four
people of working age in this country
are either unemployed or economically
inactive and claiming some sort of
benefits that's an astonishing figure i
was surprised by that what
what's going on well this uh also
includes people who aren't uh medically
capable of working it also
includes people uh with caring
responsibilities so there'll be a
variety of reasons of people who are job
ready in order to do that um well we
have seen uh we now have a record of
three million people uh on pip are of
disability benefit if you think about it
5.3 million people economically inactive
1.3 million job vacancies if you get one
out of five of those people back into
work
you fix the problem right without
further immigration is that your aim is
that the goal well my focus is on the
about 1.4 million people who we paid
benefits to who were actively looking
for work and as we've talked about some
of the um vacancies may not be readily
accessible for those people but when i
think about some of where we're trying
to fill vacancies around the country we
are also needing employers to be
flexible this is about where we are
trying to help people who have got some
challenging health conditions and how we
can help them get into work in a more
proactive way
but nevertheless uh beth there's a
number of people who went on furlough
seem to have saved a lot of money
haven't necessarily wanted to go back to
the jobs they were doing before it maybe
they found a job during furlough uh
another job which was more to their
suiting but i think we've seen a greater
thing of people um being
uh kind of wanting a different life work
balance yeah people watching this will
be thinking about their summer holidays
and looking at the baggage claim at
heathrow in absolute horror thinking is
my holiday going to get messed up
because of worker shortages the airlines
are calling out for a temporary visa
scheme
to try and sort out this short-term
issue would you rule out a temporary
visa the reason i'm asking is because
people are watching going i just want it
fixed you know i want to go on holiday i
want it fixed well indeed i don't
believe that the visa route is what is
uh being considered within government i
just know that we are helping people
currently who are out of work to find
jobs in our airports around the country
ons figures out today use uk household
incomes fell for a fourth consecutive
quarter at the start of the year it's
the longest-running decline in household
income since
1955.
adjusted for inflation incomes of 1.3
percent lower than a year ago
well look we know that inflation is high
and we know it's having an impact that's
why we responded with the cost of living
payment measure
i mean but we've added an extra 15
billion pounds the first payments will
be going out to low income households
next month uh and that be staggered
throughout the year in how we help
people as well as the money going to
every household to help with energy
costs why is it difficult in your job
though because
you are dealing with people that are
really at the bottom of income scales
that typically that they feel
price-wise is much more acutely than the
middle classes because they don't have
disposable income do you is it hard in
your job that you think i can't do
enough for people
well i do know that one of the best ways
i can help them is to help them get a
job yeah
to really boost their pay packet but i
remember in the pandemic your department
really pushed for example the 20 pounds
a week on universal credit that that
made a huge difference to people that
was a way you could cost 6 billion a
year
i mean
do you kind of think if i could i would
put that policy back
i don't anticipate a particular up
rating that's linked to 20 pounds but as
ever i will do my annual review uh later
in the year i interview gordon brown
also this week for the show and he's a
former chancellor and thinks a lot about
this too and he said to me that he's
worried that charity is becoming the
last line of defense for people
struggling instead of the welfare state
what's your response to that do you
think that's an unfair
observation as i've pointed out we've
put together just uh in a matter of a
few weeks ago or less than two months
ago a package of support of 15 billion
pounds to help and some of the criticism
of it was that it wasn't targeted enough
that those on lower incomes that it
wasn't targets enough like some of the
blanket measures like a fuel duty cut
six billion 2.4 billion pounds for that
but it was well that was part of the
earlier package in terms of uh the 22
billion pounds before okay well let's
let's talk a bit now about you
um now before you came into politics you
were
you're a scientist by background aren't
you well i did a phd in chemistry but i
didn't carry it on in work and then
you're a business woman yeah
but did you always want to go into
politics were you a young conservative
i was a young conservative i think i
grew up in liverpool in the 80s and
i'm 50 now but actually as a child i did
actually have a conservative mp people
might find that hard to believe it
wasn't for very long
and then i felt my home city of
liverpool was ruined by militant labor
and the analogy i can see with momentum
today and recently is is very
very clear
and i just realized that politics
mattered
both my parents were teachers they were
the gang part of the gang that received
their redundancy notice which was then
repealed and i remember at the time
saying to my mum this is like really
worrying she said no don't worry it's
some trick so they can we'll all get
we'll all be fine and i just thought
that's not the way to run my city and i
actually thought margaret thatcher was
doing a great job in the rest of the
country so i got engaged i didn't know
that i didn't know you were from
liverpool actually you haven't got a
liverpudlian accent at all i can turn on
the other side okay
i went to paris for the uh
for the champions league final so it was
good too i did so i didn't know this
about you i'll tell you getting into the
stadium it's like being in a mosh pit
that wasn't right wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't there was it loads of aggro there
did you get it it was i think it was
very well handled but did you find did
you have any troubles there were you
absolutely i wasn't pepper sprayed but
uh that was part of the squash honestly
it was like being in a mosh pit but you
didn't want to be
oh no it wasn't great
it wasn't frightened but it was
uncomfortable
but nevertheless it was um it wasn't
even a great result for us the other
thing that i know about you but lots of
people might not know about you is that
you're also a devoted roman catholic
now in terms of your faith does it
affect your or guide political decisions
for you at all or is it something that
you keep for sunday only is it is do you
separate those things out in your life
well i don't work i don't think i wear
my religion on my sleeve so to speak but
it's untouchable part of who i am
and i hope that comes through in a lot
of the ways that we try and help people
in my role as secretary of state we want
to be compassionate and considered
in what we're doing and helping some of
the most vulnerable people in our
society
you know there are other issues which
get decided in parliament on great
ethical issues of the day
and so of course i'll participate in
that but i'm a democrat as well and i
just realized we're coming down so i'm
going to jump to this straight this
question just in terms of women's rights
roe versus weighed uh last week the
supreme court and mayor effect the end
the constitute rights were abortion for
millions of women across the u.s the pm
said it was a move backwards step
backwards what did you think about that
well it's a u.s supreme court decision
in this country parliament's legislated
to allow access to abortion uh there
it's a different uh debate uh federal
versus uh states and the supreme court
have come a different decision on who
should decide that is it the courts or
should it be legislators we already have
the situation so abortion law isn't
going to change in this country people
will still have access to it jacob
rees-mogg the reason is he we were he's
obviously a catholic too he told me that
the number of abortions in the uk he
thought was one of the saddest aspects
of british modern life
do you agree with that
i think there's a number of things where
people either give up hope or don't
think they can cope with certain things
in a broad
varieties of way
of course i would prefer for people who
didn't have abortions but i'm not going
to condemn people that do and would you
like to see
the right to abortion shined in british
law which is now the live debate we
don't need it because we already have
legislation that provides access to
abortion and just finally
you've i've been described as one of the
fully paid up human beings in public
life
you like a drink you like a bit of
karaoke you occasionally like a cigar
um
that's your way of letting off steam
isn't it what's your signature track oh
gosh i don't know it keeps changing one
of the uh we're having a great time at
the moment it's shower and becky g there
we go dancing in the mirror singing in
the shower but no that's a slightly
different thing a few years ago i was
pretty ill it's reinforced my
joy for life
and i'll keep living life to the full
but i'm a professional always get the
work done well that's all for tonight's
show thank you to all of our guests
therese coffee celine chai chahan park
and gordon brown and thank you for
taking time to watch us
[Music]
[Music]
you